il a lancé six hommes de main
raté
c'est toi de nous pas
a encore raté tu fais exprès de
malvieille koala non c'est quoi la
brouille quoi tient un filtre et c'est
ça mais n'importe quoi qu'est ce que tu
racontes
alors pourquoi tu tires n'importe où
comme ça là bon je te dis la vérité tu
t'énerves dit moi je t'écoute bat gc pas
les toucher en fait je sers totalement
au pif quoi mais pourquoi tu fais ça
même si on est vain et qu'on essaie de
toucher le maître on ne touche jamais et
il passe entre les barres
c'est hyper chiant t'as jamais remarqué
ci est alors eh bah du coup je le suis
dit que ça servait à rien de se prendre
la tête à bien viser donc tu es en train
de te dire que maintenant tu vas
toujours tir au pif
non mais ça fait longtemps que je veux
faire deux en deux ans d'une ça fait
deux ans que tu fais semblant de tirer
je fais pas semblant de dire et je tire
n'importe où il pas parlé donc c'est
pour ça que ça fait deux ans que t'as
jamais touché personne
excuse moi mais tu as touché combien de
mecs en deux ans je te parle 0 ok sauf
que toi tu prends des cours de tir tous
les week-ends des cours de tir tous les
week-ends tu vois même pas ta fille
grandir mec tu arrives pas à toucher un
mec du bad à la fois je te veux tu cher
les mecs tuchel est parce que tu arrives
pas toucher quelqu'un mais c'est quoi ce
game dans lequel tu es rentré tu regarde
même plus ta femme dans les yeux mec ça
doit être tellement dur tu as raison je
te jure que c'est perdu la jalousie le
dire à personne mais oui oui ça me fait
mal oui la fois que j'ai vu ma fille
elle avait trois ans et maintenant par à
m'en aller au collège
c'est quoi ma femme c'est ma passion
prennent la tête tu sais quels sont les
seuls portraits du che à la maison
témoin des cibles j'ai des cibles dans
un cadre j'ai jamais toucher à ce pacte
mais moi mec m'attend je kiffe la life
break je vais tellement mieux de pluie
ah ouais bah oui c'est tellement le king
de tirer n'importe où regarde
tapez des bois j'aimerais tellement me
sentir aussi libre que toi je te jure si
tu veux le faire mais mais chez nous tu
crois que je peux le faire
allez prends ma place c'est bon c'est ok
on les rattrape
à toi deux d'or
oh
tu laves telle tâche les pocher les la
tâche est allé toucher croyable bareback
fais gaffe de mutobo la non mais vaut
mieux rester là-dessus franchement on
fera pas mieux
j'avoue quand le patron va prendre qu'un
de ses employés a touché un mec
félicitations les gars merci bosse ça
fait plaisir
[ __ ] je suis fier de vous merci bosse
à il devait tellement pas s'attendre à
se prendre une bastos les mecs tu
tellement hâte d'aller sur la chaîne du
multi prises pour voir ce qui se passait
dans la voiture des gentils pendant la
course poursuite
en fait moi c'est aurélien et multiprise
c'est notre chaîne youtube avec freddy à
nice alors viens voir la vidéo du point
de vue des gentils sur notre chaîne et
profites en pour t'abonner mais hyper
sympa
ils sont abonnés là vous pensez ça
s'appelle du gâchis mais il ya des
cailloux dans tournaire